Often, you will need to load
an external data file into R
to do some analysis
and modeling.
In this class, we'll be
working with csv files,
or comma separated value files.
This is a common
format for data files
and is easy to work with in R.
The first thing you need to
do to read in a data file
is to navigate to the
directory on your computer
where the data file is saved.
On a Mac, go to the Misc menu,
then select "Change Working
Directory...".
On a PC, go to the File menu
and select "Change dir...".
This should pop up a browsing
or navigation window.
Navigate to the folder where
you saved the data file WHO.csv
that you've downloaded
for this class,
and then select that folder.
Nothing should
have happened in R,
but if you type
getwd, and then empty
parentheses and hit Enter,
you should see the path
to the folder containing
the data set that you just
selected.
Now, read in the data
file by typing WHO =
read.csv("WHO.csv") the name of
the data file we want to read
in.
If you hit Enter, this will
save the data set in WHO.csv
to the data frame WHO.
To look at our data, there
are two very useful commands.
The first is the
str function, which
shows us the
structure of the data.
If you type str(WHO),
and hit Enter,
you can see that we
have a data frame
of 194 observations
and 13 variables.
This data set contains
recent statistics
from the World Health
Organization-- W,
H, O, or WHO-- on all countries.
The variables are the
name of the country,
the region the country is in,
the population in thousands,
the percentage of the
population under 15 and over 60,
the fertility rate or average
number of children per woman,
the life expectancy in years,
the child mortality rate which
is the number of children
who die by age five per 1,000
births, the number of cellular
subscribers per 100 population,
the literacy rate among
adults aged greater than
or equal to 15, the gross
national income per capita,
the percentage of male children
enrolled in primary school,
and the percentage
of female children
enrolled in primary school.
For each variable, str gives
us the name of the variable,
and then a description of
the type of the variable
followed by a first few
values of the variable.
We see a couple
different types here.
One is a factor variable.
Country and Region are
both factor variables.
This means that
the variables have
several different categories,
not necessarily numerical.
For example, the Region variable
has six different categories
or levels.
These include
Africa and Americas.
So each observation
in the Region variable
belongs to one of six
different categories.
For variables like
Country, where
there's 194 levels, which is
the same number of observations
we have, each value in
this variable is different.
In this case, it makes sense,
since each country name
is different.
Then we have two types of
numerical values-- integer
and then general
numerical values.
The other very useful function
to take a look at our data
is the summary function.
In your R console,
type summary and then,
in parentheses, WHO, the name of
our data frame, and hit Enter.
This gives a numerical summary
of each of our variables.
For the factor variables,
country and region,
it counts the number
of observations
in each of the
levels or categories.
So here, we see that we have
46 countries in the region
Africa, 35 in the
region Americas, etc.
For each of the
numerical values,
we see the min, first quartile,
median, mean, third quartile,
and maximum values
in that variable.
We can also see in some of the
variables that we have this
category called NA's.
This means that
some observations
are missing values
in that variable.
So for FertilityRate,
there 11 observations that
are missing the value
of FertilityRate.
When working with data
in R, it can often
be useful to subset your data.
For example, suppose we
want to create a new data
frame with only the
countries in Europe.
Let's call it WHO_Europe
and use the subset function
to subset the data
frame WHO to take
only the observations
for which Region
is exactly equal to Europe.
The subset function
takes two arguments.
The first is the
data frame we want
to take a subset of,
in this case, WHO.
And the second argument
is the criteria
for which observations of WHO
should belong in our new data
frame, WHO_Europe.
In this case, we
want the observations
for which the Region variable
is exactly equal to Europe.
The double equal sign here
means exactly equal to.
If we hit Enter and then look
at the structure of WHO_Europe,
we can see that
we now have a data
frame of 53 observations
of the same 13 variables.
Does 53 sound right?
Well, let's look back at
the summary output of WHO.
We can see in the
Region output, there
were 53 observations that
belonged in the region Europe.
So we should expect
53 observations
in our Europe subset,
which is right.
Now, suppose we want
to save this new data
frame, WHO_Europe,
to a csv file.
You can use the write.csv
function to do this.
Type write.csv, and
then in parentheses
the name of the data
frame we want to save,
WHO_Europe, comma,
and then in quotes
the name of the file
we want to save it to.
Let's call it WHO_Europe.csv.
If you hit Enter,
nothing should happen,
but you should now have a
file called WHO_Europe.csv
in the same folder that
you saved WHO.csv in.
And now that we've saved
this as a csv file,
if we're not working
with it anymore in R,
we can remove the data frame
from our current session in R.
This is often useful if you're
working with a large data
set that's taking
up a lot of space.
First, let's type ls() to see
what variables we currently
have in R. You could see
that WHO_Europe is one
of our variables.
Now, type rm for remove and
then the name WHO_Europe and hit
Enter.
If you type ls() again, you
should see that WHO_Europe is
gone.
In the next video, we'll
explore the WHO data set.